les chaussettes de l'archiduchesse sont
elles sèchent archi sèche piano panier
piano panier piano panier piano panier
brune au cri pruneaux cru pruneaux cuits
bruno cruzeau cuit premiers crus ou
cuits mélange je les ai bousculé je
devrais le mettre ailleurs 16 jacinthe
au siège dans 16 h et sec
salut c'est moi
tom sens qui il se pourrait que ce soir
je vivre l'expérience la plus marquante
de mon existence
pourquoi me demanderez-vous ça répond à
la question si je vous dis
vampires 90 hommes ils n'existent pas
sont seulement des légendes faire voir
ok désolé moment pour savoir
je me présente je suis étudiant en
deuxième année à l'université à aussonne
où je prends des cours de photographie
le sujet photos que je préfère c'est la
silhouette féminine
mais le héros de ce film ce n'est pas
moi c'est un film sur le dr chez le plus
grand professeur d'histoire de tous les
temps et vous savez quoi
c'est un vampire avant pierre jeanniot
l'histoire n'a rien trouvé de plus
rocambolesques poutre à la fin merde il
ya fort longtemps
dr g est tombé amoureux d'une jeune
humaine qui s'appelait marie prenez une
chambre puis lui ce jour funèbre dans la
chambre à coucher deux maris ils étaient
enfermés à deux il se faisait tard mais
ça leur est égal il se faisait des
papouilles
rien d'autre n'a porté quand le soleil
se couche à il l'a fort dit en tuant
l'amour de sa ville se condamner à
souffrir
[Musique]
tout le monde était furax la famille de
marie ne le laissa même pas assisté à
l'enterrement
tout ça parce qu'il l'avait tué
heureusement ce gars là est un génie il
se déguisait en frères qui se faufile à
l'intérieur pour la voir
[Musique]
à
salvo leur jet ski je n'ai jamais voulu
faire de mal tout s'est tu et le diable
en personne déguisée en homme d'église
ne fait pas l'idiot grigor
[Musique]
tu va pourrir en enfer wayne gretzky en
enfer j'y suis déjà il vient de mettre
une raclée à gregor mais avez vous
remarqué que ses canines ne sont pas
sortis depuis la mort de marie
il n'était plus capable de montrer les
crocs
or marc mari
et c'est ainsi que depuis trois siècles
docteur g est condamné à parcourir le
monde avec ses crocs défaillant en se
nourrissant exclusivement de sang animal
du moins jusqu'à il ya quelques mois
[Musique]
si tu veux mon avis deux psychologues
l'impuissance chez le vampire n'est
qu'une autre facette de l'impuissance
cher mais je ne suis pas un puissant
anti cros ne sortent plus tu appelles ça
quand je te dis simplement que la
comparaison n'est pas absurde et elle
mais dans quoi eh bien tu es impuissant
depuis le jour où tu as tué l'amour de
ta vie par accident désolé herman quoi
aller mophie saluera mari dont elle est
assez courant qu'un meurtrier de vienne
qui deviennent à puce 1 parce que très
souvent bon sens one ya un truc qui
tourne pas rond chez toi tu est que tout
ça a fonctionné mieux quand on est et
camille a oui mais pour qui seront pas
pour toi tu avoues sentais mon coeur je
le sais mais personne n'a l'expérience
des cas dans mon genre c'est de
l'expérience avec les gens et tu
ressembles à une personne comme les
autres pour moi seulement si je fais
bien mon boulot tu finiras par plus
ressembler un démon on ressemble pas à
des déments d'en but fixé mais dans la
vraie vie non non je découvre le sujet
n'y a pas beaucoup de documentation
fiable sur ton espèce les seules
références à ma disposition c'est la
culture pop
mais quoi qu'il en soit monsieur rupture
soit confié à moi
oui moi aussi
[Musique]
c'est qu'il conseillait de crise c'est
le professeur les vignerons pas remarqué
qu'il sentait la maison j'ai pris inter
chaque grande ville soit garde-à-vous
qu'elle existe pas tu l'a inventé ou
coucher du soleil tous les deux sont
vives et gaies et toi admet que tu
schlingue la merde toute la journée
quoi quand les gars
la voiture je suis désolé ma chérie j'ai
oublié mon chapeau tu es vraiment une
confiance tout juste cent ans ted est la
raison
il
[Musique]
non pas du tout ça arrive que les
premières années du mal à choisir leur
spécialité ce n'est pas grave
après tout c'est difficile de savoir ce
qu'on va faire du reste de sa vie quand
on bat quoi 18 ses 19 ans à vous avez un
doublé qu'est-ce qui lé ainsi nuit
pourquoi dites vous cela
entrée quand on parle du vampire et
quand on parle du loup
je viens de terminer twilight et depuis
je n'arrête pas de penser aux vampires
ça c'est le professeur gretzky alors
jetez pas s'en vanter
c'est un fabuleux professeur d'histoire
il m'a semblé contrarié mais pour cause
mais de façon positive et pour être
honnête avec vous les étudiants
l'adorent
apparemment les vampires ont des
rapports sexuels qui dure toute la nuit
que pensez-vous des loirs sipa ces
conneries crise ton nom cache quoi c'est
l'université si papa si on vote à droite
dire conneries votre fille raison même
certains de nos enseignants emploie le
mot conneries prend dans leur cour c'est
scandaleux
et vous avez raison je réglais ça assez
bavardé jeudi seulement titre est le
chien peut pas pas je n'aime pas se
focaliser me suis à la fac tu entends à
la fac au fred grèce était ravissante
calais schille pas faire sa chambre
située en bas c'est chouette hein mais
c'est clair tête je t'en prie désolé
tenait hier les gars je vous présente
crise et voici son père ted ils sont
dans la même fraternité que moi ravi de
rencontrer monsieur vous lasser car il
savait bonjour ni lui cet homme
bonjour quoi c'est un plaisir de vous
rencontrer vraiment je dois y aller ma
puce
alicia prend soin de ma petite fille
d'accord fred oui je la ferai cas je
veux dire ce sera fait je vais rassurer
alors chris tu comptes intègrent une
sororité oui j'ai été recruté par les
cas pas au micro les caps aoc une pente
de choses vous êtes en quelle fraternité
déjà on est détesté des oueds et est
aidé en même temps en anglais ça veut
dire n est
on est les sigma tau delta et ya la
merveille
pourquoi la parra puis il a une maladie
cutanée
mais comme profit déchire monsieur
gretzky c'est ce type
oui il enseigne histoire qui se souvient
j'ai essayé de convaincre de choisir ce
quoi oui oui je vais peut-être me
inscrire en fin de compte 7 après mon
conseiller tout le monde l'a d'or il est
génial ce mec dont conseillers dont a
parlé oui il passé à son bureau quand
j'étais monsieur lévy n'a crié quand on
parle du vampire quand on parle du
vampire
bienvenue aux cours d'histoire niveau 2
je suis le professeur gretzky
y at il de nouveau parmi vous je dois
être très populaire mais ces deux là tu
skies je suis sûr qu on vous le demande
souvent mais votre nom c'est un hommage
à wayne gretzky
pour l'anecdote je m'appelais wayne
gretzky et bien avant que wayne gretzky
ne soit nommé wayne gretzky je suis sûr
qu'il est plus vieux que vous il a dans
les cinquante ans non mon nom n'est pas
un hommage il aimerait bien wayne
gretzky ne faisait pas encore partie de
la nhl
quand je suis venu au monde si ça c'est
pas une [ __ ] de coïncidence ça va à
l'état désolé dr g ce n'est rien on va
on étudie et des coïncidences en
histoire tu réalises que tu as vraiment
énervé ta fille tout à l'heure je ne
vais pas renoncer à mes croyances
uniquement parce qu'aujourd'hui elle
entre à l'université puisqu'on aborde le
sujet je voulais te demander non tu vois
ron de l'épicerie bio
il a grandi chez les amish et il dit que
les amish peuvent sans problème
s'exposer au soleil et il a des miroirs
chez lui aussi oui mais on n'aime pas
être photographiée tu vas la messe n'a
mère était catholique
le mari je ne te crois pas quand tu dit
être ami j'ai cessé d'y croire il ya des
années je suis quoi alors selon toi ça
m'est égal
j'ai toujours mis ça sur le compte d'une
légère névroses je me suis dit que ce
serait plus simple de laisser couler
mais tu sais quoi tu vas perdre ta
relation avec ta fille si tu n'y prend
pas garde
ted il ya des choses en moi que même
avec de la bonne volonté je ne pourrai
jamais changé sur lesquels je n'aime pas
m'étendre toi mieux que quiconque tue
devraient le comprendre
qu'est ce que tu veux dire si quand la
dernière fois que j'ai eu envie de me
faire l'amour
non le terrain juste rassure toi je
mettrai ça sur le compte d'une légère
névroses et donc dans le feu de l'action
ils sectionnent le bras de ce type mais
ne le fera pas avec il utilise ses
propres mains pour le poignet et gengis
avait vraiment un merveilleux sens de
l'humour
je veux dire il ne riais jamais autant
que durant l'acte physique d'amour je me
souviens d'une fois quand j'étais
enfermé chez lui quelque part un jour
donc il prenait du bon temps avec une
femme qui avait une jambe plus courte
que l'autre au moment où on enlève la
chaussure de la jambe plus courte
il éclate de rire tous les hommes dans
les grandes voisines se met aussitôt à
rire quand on a tous quand ils ont levé
ils ont vu gengis khan qui avait enfilé
la chaussure à son pied
[Rires]
sans ce qu'il me manque
façon de parler bien entendu ça me
manque de lire sur le sujet et bien vous
n'avez qu'à lire d'autres bouquins oui
vous avez raison je pourrai mais ce ne
serait pas tout à fait la même chose ça
ne serait plus aussi drôle aussi drôle
que quoi y aura sa au partiel
oui tout ce que je dis en cours peut
tomber à l'examen jeu plaisant vous
serez pas interrogé là-dessus mais c'est
de l'histoire c'est vrai étonne c'est
l'histoire
je n'ai pas pris le temps de vous dire
que j'ai beaucoup aimé votre devoir du
semestre dernier celui dans lequel vous
traitiez de l'impuissance chez les
meurtriers merci mme excellent travail
on devrait dire j découverte de toutes
choses c'est vrai pas propos de moi cela
va de soi je vous vois en classe mardi
très bien au revoir au revoir bonjour
quand on parle du vampire je te prie de
m'excuser j'étais nerveuse je venais de
fixer une étudiante jeudi ce qui me
traversaient l'esprit le secret
professionnel c'est une notion abstraite
pour toi je sais ne t'en fais pas comme
si quelqu'un les gras on en reparlera
plus tard j'ai un cours à donner ni à
quelle vitesse du court les 40 yards
quel rapport avec le reste moi si
j'étais un vampire je sais que je ferai
partie de la nfl membres tu ferais un
frichti d'enfer j'en reviens pas que
lauren veuille organiser une nouvelle
collecté 200 j'aimerais qu'on change
qu'on fasse
je sais pas moi il collecte de plasma
c'est quoi une collecte de plasma crise
je te jure raté la fille la plus cool
que je connaisse toi au moins tu as pas
peur de poser des questions aux fred
saluer cru saluer ce que je t'ai
et les fier regardez il ya la merveille
là bas
[Musique]
à
qu'est ce qui lui arrive
[Musique]
je ne pouvais plus me contrôler c'était
pareil avec marie je parvenais à garder
le contrôle dans la journée
mais dès le coucher du soleil répondait
plus de rien dont 300 lang sané
d'impuissance quelques séances avec moi
et bon d'accord tu n'es pas guéri mais
c'est un bon début
je ne sais même pas qui aime un jeu de
dire qu'ils allaient à leytron viagra
pour vampire c'est évident que tu crois
pas ou que oui et moi je suis ton
direction de quatre heures mon grand
émoi jusqu'à ce que tu sois capable de
montrer les crocs tout seul là j'ai pas
exactement sorti les crocs j'ai plutôt
ressenti comme un picotement depuis
coûte mans fourmillements le fait est
que si tu étais resté plus longtemps
dans les parages la frontière crèverait
de trouille à l'heure qu'il est c'était
son portrait craché
ça ne me surprend pas ah non non quand
on y réfléchit la nature crée une telle
multitude de visages que tu allais
forcément croisé le sien jours bien
posté un exemple personnage autrefois
traiter une jeune femme qui ressemblait
trait pour trait à ma seconde épouse je
te jure ces répliques exactes de la tête
aux pieds c'était j'ai failli perdre le
droit d'exercer à cause d'elle
mais elle en valait la peine
tout comme s'est justifié de prendre des
risques pour cette belle plante c'est
très étrange de ne pas vous voir
ensemble tom et vous ouais cet horaire
lui convenait pas il va chez le coiffeur
de soir et moi je peux pas le matin
c'est dommage oui dit je me demandais
quand vous êtes entré dans le bâtiment
je vous ai vu trébucher ah oui oui en
effet c'était parce que j'ai tout à coup
j'ai eu la tête qui bourdonnaient un bon
jour content de voir que vous allez
mieux vous sembliez panique et du coup
c'est seulement que je hais les bourdons
monsieur gretzky oui vous êtes je suis
chris keller et je ne suis pas sur vos
listes mais celui savoir si si je peux
vous prendre devant la classe situez
vous pendre dans ma classe oui il c'est
possible ouais il a su aucun souci
excusez moi je viens tout juste
d'apprendre que ma mère était décidé que
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je
aaa est pété un plomb de taux bas
[Musique]
docteur g
quoi
je sens votre souffle dr g vous
accueille
[Musique]
il
d'or ii
[Musique]
paris mon pauvre petit [ __ ]
c
je vous en ai rapporté 1
[Musique]
m
si je crois qu'une fois qu'elle aura
pris le rythme des cours il aura plus de
temps à consacrer à d'autres trucs comme
on veut qu'elle ait une place dans le
cours du dr j quand on parle du vampire
clis nous a raconté ce que me dit
monsieur divine au boulet franchement
vous trouverez aussi
non en réalité illico et toutes
portaient lé dr g vous savez pas si
vulgaire aux règles générales j'évite
les grossièretés
ça sonnait bien pourtant ça va vous
donner le choc le choc comment ça je
veux dire avec votre mère qui vient de
décéder
oui vous forcez pas grave je veux dire à
un moment ça fait des années qu'il est
morte
ou plutôt ça faisait des années et
qu'elle était mourante je m'y étais
préparé vous aviez quand même l'air
bouleversé en quittant la salle oui je
voulais pas qui lui veulent tous ses
organes au fait mon ami chris vous savez
elle est hyper motivé par votre cours
chris keller oui c'est bien elle
c'est une fille brillante sans pour
autant être un rat de bibliothèque et
les super
vous verrez il va vous plaire j'en suis
sûr pas dans un sens sexuel attention
c'est presque je veux dire vous allez
l'apprécier c'est tout
je vois on est bien d'accord le sexe
c'est sale sur ce il faut que je file me
préparer je dois me préparer pour mes
étudiants n'entendent elle a rien de
sexuel pour les cours cette fois je me
mets en route et à vous deux je vous dis
à très vite sexuellement
le sexe est sale
[Musique]
à roisin quad ma soeur ma vie rentrée
oui vous m'avez bien je n'ai pas fait
prier je suis désolé j'avais prévu 2
j'avais prévu de dix tonnes en dix ans
leur bureau mais il s'agit plus
maintenant
dommage que je m'appelle pas d'art je
sais ce n'est pas tout ça vous feriez
sûrement mieux d'y aller 1
enfin je vous chassent pas je voulais
dire après une brève mais néanmoins
agréable minute ou deux mais ensuite
navré je veux pas être impoli mais je
dois encore préparer mes cours
santes magnifique tu l'a toujours été
pardon à tous ceux là dessus j'ai dit
oups de la puce
non juste avant sa as je crois pas avoir
dit quoi que ce soit tenez j'ai ramassé
votre thermostat vous vous êtes sauvés
du coup j'ai nettoyé
suis je suis navré pour votre maman
oui par oui pour toute cette affaire a
été plutôt pénibles
vous allez bien non je viens me pisser
dessus allez vous en ok passer demain
mon bureau d'accord oui à quelle heure
le matin ça m'arrangerait que vous
veniez matin très bien
[Musique]
ça rend bien là quand même qui sera ta
première victime en sais rien le courant
est bien passé avec la meuf de fresnes a
été vraiment c'est bon elle est pas
chasse gardée laisse la place aux autres
si tu tentes rien ce fait que deux jours
qu'elle est là lâchez moi avec elle je
dis seulement qu'elle a envie de moi et
tu te comportes comme un légaliste
non sans blague les gars vous pensez
qu'elle préfère avoir quoi mais joli
petit festayres où le gros cul flasque
de tom qui t'ont délit d'initié ni l'un
ni l'autre abruti h plaisante je passe
encore battu et les grognasses mars m
accuse sion la porte et que ça saute
l'udc salue je vous apporte des boissons
fait d'alcool non des boisson
énergisante
excusez moi un instant je rêve c'était
sa mère plutôt sa soeur jumelle tu peux
dire il est trop sexy c'est hallucinant
les deux soeurs tu mates
oui je voulais faire une surprise si le
droit comment en montrant toutes mes
copines à quel point c'est bizarre que
je n'arrivais pas à dormir c'est pas
nouveau que je sache c'est penny tous
tes conneries amish parfois les
conneries amish des gens ne sont pas ce
que tu crois
mais si être amish c'est si important à
tes yeux pourquoi tu m'as pas élevé
comme ça au fond j'ai toujours souhaité
et d'enseigner nos coutumes seulement
j'ignorais j'ignorais comment m'y
prendre
mais il est encore temps d'essayer non
non c'est plus la peine
regarde moi j'ai 19 ans il est trop tard
j'en ai plus rien à faire merci pour les
boissons
de rien
y'a du monster les pétasses et d'hommes
ouais ce qu'on dit sur les cas pas au
c'est vrai tu crois c'est des jonas fait
j'ai vu leurs clips sur youtube elle
n'aurait jamais dû accepter d'être une
capable
bonsoir chéri jolies chaussures tu t'es
décidé à aller voir crise oui je vais
rendu visite
ça a été lamentable chérie tu es tu ne
comprends pas toi tu proche d'elle je
suis sa mère et elle muette eu la caméra
brossé
tarif jamais de la remonter le temps
jusqu'à quand
il ya très longtemps
hamon
[Musique]
oui monsieur catski
oui lui même entré dans je vous en prie
c'est vous que faites vous là un jeu je
croyais que vous vouliez que je passe
maintenant à c'est ce que j'ai dit en
quoi puis-je vous aider à
c'est vrai
la fiche d'inscription tarder la fameuse
que janice les profs refusent à 6,1 et
le précieux sésame pour être franc avec
vous crise il n'y a déjà plus de place
dans le cours de soi mais il y en a une
qui s'est libérée dans celui du matin oh
c'est celui de 10h30 tout à fait homme
il semblerait que barry personnes
étaient inscrits à ce court mais il ne
viendra plus puisqu'il est porté disparu
oui j'ai appris c'est affreux oui c'est
tragique mais quand dieu ferme une porte
il ouvre une fenêtre ailleurs il est à
présent vous pouvez vous inscrire en
histoire
un jeu j'ai pas enfreint le règlement
rassurez moi
le règlement qui fait les règles de
toute façon j'en sais rien bon on est
parent je vois en cours ok je chercherai
d'accord je serai le professeur pervers
c'est pour les cours perverse toi-même
et voit la crise profites en pour
l'inviter à la fête
qu'est ce que j'allais faire tout ça y
est vous de ça va saluer crise alors que
les taux courts degré de queyries ça y
est mais celui du soir est déjà complet
j'ai une place dans celui de 10h30 cool
je me suis là aussi tu sens c'est
l'attrapé via des cons ça fait mal
c'était une marque d'affection et
puisqu'on parle d'affection et
ravissante crise et puis tu sentais mon
on vous laisse crise j'ai été ravi de
voir que je retrouve pas en train de
vous pilotez dans mon histoire les [ __ ]
ouais comme si ça arrivait alors tu vas
te décider à l'inviter à cette soirée tu
parles de coire crise la plus belle
fille que j'ai jamais vu dès que je peux
savoir ce que vous parlez on discute de
choses et d'autres et ne rien de très
intéressant
fred tu comptes m'invitait à une fête
non non
ok faut que j'y aille je dois acheter
des bouquins pour les cours et bas à une
c4
on joue en histoire salut tu m'expliquer
ce qui t'a pris je m'étais dit qu'il
fallait que je t'en parle
mais pour une raison qui m'échappe g ca
des revenus pile quand jared et cal se
sont cassés aurait au moins pu attendre
qu'ils soient plus à côté j'ai vraiment
désolé mec je suis paumé surprise figure
toi tout individu qui entraient dans
cette chambre sans être annoncées
étaient exécutés sur le champ soit à
l'épée soit à l'arbalète
heureusement pour guenièvre à cette nuit
fatidique était aussi une nuit de pleine
lune un cible vous êtes gagnant alors
que lancelot était couché dans le plus
simple appareil permettait que j'aurai
mon pantalon
non je plaisante je vais pas vous
infliger ça alors que lancelot se
reposait nu comme un ver il tendit la
main vers son épée et à ce même instant
la lune éclaire à guenièvre révélant
chacun des traits de son visage pâle aux
taches de rousseur abel marqué c'est à
cet instant et en ce lieu que lancelot
su qu'il était prêt à tout perdre son
pouvoir son titre et son rang pour cette
seule nuit interdite pour cette très
longue compromettantes nuit avec cette
bête saab et aux chevrons je croyais que
camelot n'était qu'une légende
tom vous apprendrez dans mon cours que
chaque légende commence par une vérité
est que chaque vrai héros doit être prêt
à risquer tout ce qu'il possède pour
obtenir ce qu'il désire
oui voilà gerbex averous asseyez-vous
lancelot est ténue le prof un pantalon
fin de la parenthèse on reprend
tout sur la capot moteur de notre mairie
c'est merveilleux
cave même quand j'étais vous essayez de
raffi télé votre guitare
non non à vrai dire je viens plutôt de
casser celle-ci vous ne voulez pas
lâcher l'histoire après la première
leçon aux non non non pas du tout au
contraire secours ma que vous diriez m'a
beaucoup parlé ça va pas dire fins et
vous savez ce qui est drôle avec cette
légende en réalité c'est que bien
souvent l'histoire d'amour est mal
interprété ce que beaucoup ignorent au
sujet des roi arthur
c'est qu'il était un parfait connard ça
déchire pas vrai
certaines personnes vont trouver ça
ignoble à cause de la différence d'âge
encore auquel connaissent pas leur vraie
différence d'âge parce que sinon elle se
vomir dessus je tire mon chapeau à dr
j'ai cependant parce qu'il n'y a que
deux femmes sur terre qui ressemble à
crise et à sa maman et ses crises et sa
maman et ce gars là c'est envoyer la
mère et la fille pour frais des mois ce
serait déjà le pied de pouvoir les
frôler dans la foule
le seul vrai problème dans cette
histoire c'est que fred en a souffert
vas-y film
à toi freddie prinze une teinte est
lourd avec des surnoms de merde
l'usoc raconte comment tu prends le elle
le fait que chris se tape docteur g ou
par curiosité
pas si mal étant donné que c'est la
rumeur la plus débile que j'ai entendu
toute ma vie du campus et d'eau courante
couchent ensemble c'est pas parce qu'il
s'enferme dans son bureau qu'ils
couchent ensemble ça veut rien dire
bah ça se pourrait rien à voir
nous on dit ça histoire que tu sois au
courant ouais pour que tu sois pas
surprise tu vois son nom dans ma liste
la fameuse liste de ses conquêtes
sexuelles ya peu de chances pour que ça
arrive
fred vous êtes deux enflure vient
confiner les verts tout le monde est au
courant que vous vous envoyer en l'air
crise pourquoi tu refuse de l'admettre
parce que ça vous regarde pas c'est tout
tu vas le voir dans son bureau genre
tous les jours oui scud du court et ça
s'arrête là
on garde nos pantalons du budo que vous
les garder sur l'autre genre vous
échangez vos pantalons
je crois qu on a échangé nos pantalons
je sais que ça woerth en date est il ya
bon moment tu me conduit chez
chiropracteur
oui
quand elle avait 12 ans elle a dit à son
père qu'un jour elle voudrait se marier
avec moi comment tu sais ça me l'a dit
tiens quand on parle du vampire hunter g
ouais et il est avec chris sens
montre je sais combien écoute cet
appareil non elle monte dans sa voiture
car
oh non sans dec dr juste à petit duc six
minutes c'est pas ma dulcinée
c'est la dulcinée de personnes
il se passe rien entre eux tu te fais
des films tu as vu aussi à les monter
avec lui dans sa caisse si bas parce
qu'elle monte dans la voiture de
quelqu'un qu'il couche avec lui elle est
montée dans la mienne je sais faire
arrête de mentir
docteur geste ma nuit ici
[Musique]
ça fait combien de temps que tu t'en vas
en l'air avec cette fille quelques jours
enfin disons plutôt cinq semaines donc
pour toi je ne suis qu'un bouffon c'est
ça pour que tu m'avais dit c'est une de
mes élèves c'est encore une gamine mais
tu sens maintenant les gros comment 13
199 tu as tu peux me les montre et
maintenant comme si j'allais faire ça
dans ton bureau
bon le combat n'a je dois poser la
question mise à part in combien de
personnes au total as-tu viguier klasen
je te demande pas de m'aider à tuer au
jeu soit oui si tu savais comme ça me
soulage que tu me dises inde non mais
c'est sûr que jusqu'ici je menais pas
large
il a coutume a retiré un gros bois de la
conscience hu ok sauf que il ya ce
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi vous les durs
devenir un vampire à part entière je
croyais que je me sentirai mieux j'avais
pas pensé que j'allais tuer entendons
nous bien la renaissance je pouvais
signer des gens rien qu'à cause de leurs
allées ridicule puis quand j'ai
rencontré marie a changé ma vie du tout
où tu ne veux pas commettre de meurtre
tu ne veux pas jouer en nfl alors qu'est
ce que tu veux eh bien tu hésites pas de
m'aider à me sentir mieux
je remarque simplement que tu devras la
laisser s'en aller un jour où l'on tue
c'est mais regarde toi mon vieux tu
seras nouveau les croûtes avec une fille
devait ressentir ce que tu n'as pas
ressentie depuis environ trois siècles
sur le papier c'est l'idéal
tu sais pourquoi j'éprouve ça parce que
quand tu avais crise et gacé moment
magique où pendant une brève secondes
c'est comme si marie était là que je
l'avais pas dessus il faut le moment
passé elle retourne dans l'au delà
je me réveillais elle s'évanouit le jour
me ramena à ma nuit
qu'est-ce que je fiche avec une lolita
de 19 ans - qu'est ce que je ferais moi
écoute cette gamine te permet de te
retrouver laisse vous une chose bonjour
étrangères
salut ça faisait un bail oui métallisé
tellement de choses je vois même pas
comment on en vient à coucher avec un
prof pas un jour je suis allé le voir
dans son bureau
j'ai enlevé mon manteau et supporter
rien dit pourquoi tu me racontes soit
parce que ferais tu dois être la seule
personne de mon entourage à qui je peux
tout dire il ya eu une fois on était
tous les deux dans son bureau n'était
genre très intime du coucher avec lui
oui mais pendant tout le temps on était
occupé à le faire je n'arrêtais pas de
penser à toi
non non non je me suis mal exprimé et je
tiens ça n'a rien à voir avec ça je ne
pense pas à toi de cette façon ça jamais
été le cas je pense pas à toi de cette
façon non plus c'est uniquement la
mémoire musculaire
tu crois d'autres choses j'avais cru que
qu'une fois à l'université tout serait
différent
j'imaginais kong landrais comprendra des
cuites ce genre de truc que j'allais
profiter de la vie d'étudiante à fond au
lieu de m'envoyer en l'air à tout bout
de champ avec un de mes profs tu me
conseilles quoi fred
laisse tomber monsieur gretzky et
dépêche-toi avant de changer d'avis
samedi
vieux vient par là à métaux que je dis
faut que tu vois ça c'est grise c'est
quand elle était avec dr g ouais merci
de me le rappeler
non on regarde si la crise il ya le
parapluie de dr g mais lui n'est pas sur
la photo tu as vu un merde c'est dingue
j'y crois pas tu sais quoi tu devrais me
rajouter avec photoshop pour que je me
sente encore plus débile je te jure que
je n'ai pas photoshopée s'est elle dit
une interro sur ce bouquin ce serait
cool d'éviter de faire du bruit la ja le
parapluie la crise ou et docteur g je
suis pas aussi bon pour les retouches
j'en suis même loin d'ailleurs preuve
c'est la crise la ja le pare pluie est
toujours pas de dr g pourquoi tu octobre
j'aide à paris sur aucune des photos que
j'ai prises
vous avez les cheveux légèrement plus
foncé que les siens l'époque et elle les
porte est coupée à hauteur des épaules
maryline mesurait un mètre 66 quand elle
se donnait bien droites et jfk faisait 1
m 82 elle aimait donc porter les talons
haut quand il a recevait dans le bureau
ovale car elle aimait regarder dans les
yeux mais cette liaison peser à givry il
aimait son épouse maryline n'était
qu'une extraction moyens faire oublier
castro
sabato tu veux tout j'ai un chat dans la
gorge
les jours raccourcissent tu dois être
dépêchés pourquoi parce que le soleil va
se coucher
je te jure à croire que tu es un loup
garou être comme ça toujours partante
pour aller au cinéma demain si c'est
pour voir un autre vous dit allen je
préfère que tu viens me sens moi j'en ai
ras le cul tu t'es sorti de vieux j'ai
pas encore l'âge
ces conneries là pourquoi on peut pas
sortir le soir comme des gens normaux
je suis pas une personne normale non tu
exactement comme ma mère tu te rends
supérieur à tout le monde et tu sais
quoi
parfois quand on couche ensemble c'est
pas à toi que je pense je pense à une
autre femme à chaque fois
harry tu dois sûrement te retourner dans
sa tombe alors qu'il genre j'en ai rien
à [ __ ] de son avis à celles là et elle
n'est pas morte
quoi ma mère est toujours vivante a dit
qu'elle devait sûrement sorte un nez
dans sa tombe
j'ai dit que marie devait sûrement se
retourner dans sa tombe alors qu'il
était si tu fais exprès ou quoi
je te le dire en quelle langue dit ça
que quand les gens sont morts et c'est
pas le cas
ta mère s'appelle marie oui tu le savais
déjà
non je n'aurais pas oublié ce détail
c'est son nom ça défrise c'est quoi son
nom de jeune fille pourquoi tu veux
savoir ça parce que je veux le savoir
c'est tout cellou pinsky
win
ça va au lavage qu'est ce qui t'arrive
au visage je croyais devoir père du mari
[Musique]
après je lui si tu es vraiment un loup
garou
je suis méchant
[Musique]
à
marie crise crise allait encore en vie
merde merde merde merde merde
ok ou si c'est pas joli joli ça ok
[Musique]
salut bonjour est ce que marie est là
elle est au cinéma
sûrement un woody allen aucune idée on
se connaît on a déjà dû se croiser en
ville est ce que par hasard elle a une
peau extraordinaire paris c'est bizarre
comme question vous auriez une photo
d'elle à montrer ma femme n'aime pas
être prise en photo bien sûr c'est vrai
navré ceci lui appartient bonne journée
et merci
[Musique]
merde
point
si j'ai bien suivi tu croyais christ et
cd mais elle est encore en vie marie qui
était morte et enterrée est allé voir à
woody allen au cinéma elle était sans
doute dans le coma quand ils l'ont mise
en terre et comme on ne vérifiez pas le
pouls à cette époque là mais si sa mère
est un vampire crise ne devrait-elle pas
être né vampires non ça ne fonctionne
pas comme ça c'est comme l'herpès c'est
pas parce que la mer est contaminée que
son enfant le sera aussi
donc tu dois amener la victime dans un
état proche de la mort et une fois ce
stade tu arrêtes pour la transformer en
vampire
non il suffit de boire un demi litre de
sang c'est tout c'est ce que je donne
autour du sens à danser comme dans
twilight à du poison dans les crocs j'ai
mieux compris d'où venait cette croyance
ridicule c'est pas la morsure qui
contestait le fait de boire le sang
c'est tellement simple que ça en devient
stupide oui ici là je trouverai le
poignet versé son sang dans un verre il
buvait deux mains tu serais un vampire
je suis partant je regrette d'avoir
transformé crise en vampire j'ignore
comment ça va se terminer comme dans un
conte de fées mon vieux comme un conte
de fées qui durera pour l'éternité
je serai mieux d'être présent quand elle
se réveillera bonne idée je t'accompagne
hockey crise
et merde
c'est quoi le bio il te vole sa chérie
où ils te vole sa chérie et ensuite il
la transforme en vampire
tu réalises que dans les deux cas ça
craint heureusement pour moi les
vampires ça n'existe pas donc j'ai pas à
m'inquiéter du premier scénario
il faut combien de profs c'est dingue ça
c'est vrai quand on parle du vampire
d'acteurs g qu'est ce qui vous amène
dans le coin à cette heure avancée de la
nuit il est 9h30
c'est ce que je dis l'heure du crime
bref est ce qu'on peut vous offrir un
truc vous voulez peut-être quelque chose
à boire
non ça ira en réalité je cherche chris
chris keller merci mais on connaît son
nom de famille y en a qui prenaient leur
bain avec elle quand il était gosse
vous l'avez vu c'est important vous avez
regardé dans votre voiture gt qu'en ce
moment elle il passe pas mal de temps je
vous en prie et si vous avez la moindre
information
et l'homme de sigma fois un feu de camp
sur la falaise qu'est ce que voulez vous
les jeux doit la retrouver c'est tout tu
crois toujours pas que ça a vampire non
seulement un gros connard doublé d'un
fils de [ __ ] faut que je te présente
plus de 1000
[Musique]
désolé mon grand rêve est pas le choix
salut crise t'as jamais appris à frapper
combien de personnes à tuer ça fait 29
avec lui une crise il faut qu'on parle
de quoi tu veux qu'on parle du fait que
tu aies un vampire à présent et 29 quand
même assez pas rien il ya des règles que
tu dois connaître et je vais te les
enseigner comme quoi il faut que tu
apprennes entre autres de coiffer sans
miroir ou encore comment éviter
d'exposer au soleil comment ne pas
laisser de victime en vie derrière toi
afin qu'elles ne deviennent pas des
vampires et pourquoi moi tu vas laisser
en vie hein parce que je n'ai jamais eu
l'intention de tenir écoute et il faut
qu'on discute des autres possibilités de
quoi tu parles bien par exemple boire du
sang animal n'a pas eu mon message
si j'ai goûté cette merde que tu as
laissé au frigo avec le temps on s'y
fait si t'as pas les couilles d'assumer
ce que tu es c'est ton problème rien de
forcé être comme toi je sais que pour
toi cette situation c'est tout nouveau
et c'est certainement très difficile non
à vrai dire c'est assez facile regarde
aide-moi à nettoyer ce chantier on en
parlera après tu sais quoi
[Musique]
mais
sa teinte cinéma
c'est
le
ah oui oui tu
tantôt c'est est cramé
je demande le divorce
j'ai bien méritée en ce moment
un jour j'ai tué un prêtre qui disait
que je n'avais pas tabou j'ai tué un
quarterback qui avait des sentiments
pour moi c'est vrai que tu n'arrivais
plus à sortir des crous en moi alors à
vrai dire j'ai eu quelques soucis de 7,1
mais ensuite il m'est arrivé un truc
super drôle alors attention pas drôle
anjan rai avant c'était plutôt drôle
dans le sens nous intéressant tu vois
bref tu vois ta fille crise oui donc
d'où tu la connais de l'université sais
rien mais tu sais qu'entre vous la
ressemblance est criante on dirait ton
sauzier tel accord oui il pourrait être
jumelles est donc enfin avec reese mais
cros sont ressortis et depuis elle et
moi on couche ensemble mais je suis pas
amoureux d'elle rassure toi en plus on
est sur le point de rompre
je voulais aussi te dire que j'avais
transformer en vampire et qu'elle avait
déjà tué 29 personnes
je pensais à toi à chaque fois il vaut
mieux que tu t'en as you marry sors de
chez moi
c
là
[Musique]
k
il préfère faire l'amour pendant la
journée
un bisou peuvent du soleil ça les calme
après l'orgasme
je fais toujours la cloud qui de notre
visage quoi qu'y at il
vous n'aimez pas le seul ce nom
certainement que j'adore ça sauf que je
vois pas en quoi ça nous aide de vous
écouter parler de vos multiples
partenaires au fil des ans j'ai dessiné
plus d'un millier de portraits
donc si votre homme à des coucougnettes
il est maintenant
[Musique]
et si tu là aussi vous avez fait l'amour
avec lui non non rien avec lui
dieu sait que j'ai essayé je les
rencontrais à coney island en 1986 il
disait qu'il avait déjà aimé une femme
avant et que ça lui suffisait il m'a
offert un esquimau comment est-ce que
simple il ne l'a jamais dit mais on sert
non je me rappelle bien qu'est ce que
c'était c'était la merveille
là j'ai rendez vous avec elle mais je te
rejoins tu m'as temps 2 1
merci vous rêvez dessus tu es sûr et
vous m cadets l'époux fief où elles sont
toutes passées
3 quel son bowling trop ringard c'est de
l'absinthe
t'as même pas idée de ce que tu rates
comme vous tout on ne savait pas qu au
t3 vous passé j'ai un truc qui va vous
exploser le cerveau c'est quoi suis moi
août et mi temps fou et grosse [ __ ]
tu veut assouvir un fantasme lesbien
avec moi approche ya là tu as envie de
boeny shot
[Musique]
en crise je suis contente qu'on prenne
ce chemin là toi et moi moi aussi
[Musique]
mais c'est dégueu c'est pas vrai quoi
vous me remercierez demain mais ça a
l'air bien parti allait aussi tué
presque oui pourquoi tu lui a avoué pour
crise je pense qu'il le fallait d'accord
fichiers toutes ces autos thérapie nous
voilà de retour elle que ce n'est pas un
tas les mains fripé j'aurais pas cru
voir ça sur un vampire ça fait bizarre
sinon c'est beaucoup 29
oui si colas et actualise tu trouves que
c'est rien je bats il réagit pas
toulouse 19 victimes la première année
c'est ce qu'on appelle un insert à tout
coup thermique ben quoi c'est du roumain
ça veut dire super vampire ça désigne
ceux qui mordent par plaisir ils tuent
beaucoup plus que ce qu'ils peuvent pas
ce gars là est encore v non il s'est
endormi au soleil tu dois l'éliminé pas
vrai
des tags arrête je croyais qu'on devait
le tuer en utilisant la lumière du
soleil
de cette façon si c'est pas un vampire
ou risquent pas de finir en taule tu te
fous de moi ça fait cinq semaines que tu
me rabâche que tu es sûr que c'est un
vampire et j'en suis sûr
mais je prévois une marge d'erreur par
précaution
[Musique]
you dr g vous vous êtes bien foutu m'a
carrément quoi vous m'avez piquer ma
copine je vois pas de quoi vous parlez
on a une faute aux brevets vous avez une
photo de moi on vous laissera même la
voix si vous venez ici passer là moi je
suis trop crevé pour approcher prends
toi le soleil dans ta sale tronche de
vampires bataille pour moi ça va
maintenant
[Musique]
je croyais qu'il devait trouver connais
j'ai pas le temps pour ces pays
c'est du noyer à voter j'aurais aucun
mal à vous pulvérisez alors arrêté ok on
peut parler seulement si vous promettez
de pâma mon meilleur pote pitié pitié
pitié je n'aurais pas j'aurais pas pu
toutes façons pas avec tout ce qui se
passe dans ma vie personnelle
vous devriez vous asseoir je m'assieds
pas là dessus c'est ce à quoi ils ont
servi bien n'avez qu'a vous appuyez
quelque part et si je préfère rester
debout fait ce qui vous chante
ce que j'essaie de vous dire c'est que
j'ai une nouvelle pas facile à vous
annoncer et qu'il vaut mieux vous soyez
assis pour l'entendre vraiment qu'est ce
qui peut être pire que de découvrir que
le meilleur prof que vous ayez jamais eu
est un vampire et qui s'envoient en
l'air à tout bout de champ avec votre
âme soeur un y à pied encore quoi vous
l'avez tué non j'ai fait d'elle un
vampire et à présent on doit la tuer
[ __ ] sais je suis qu'un gros fils de
[ __ ] sale bâtard et un gros [ __ ]
je n'ai jamais souhaité en arriver là
mais elle est hors de contrôle et je
doit l'arrêter
comment je l'ignorent encore vous voulez
un coup de main vous êtes trop nuls les
gars attend j'admets kébé canon et tout
le bazar mais mais elle en avait rien à
faire de ta gueule et lille mais
maintenant c'est une espèce de démons
des enfers
j'en ai rien à battre dites nous ce
qu'on doit faire
pourquoi il faut que ce soit du frêne
déjà aussi bien ouais ce que j'explose
au soleil
pourquoi suis-je encore allergique aux
cacahuètes alors après avoir tué crise
on passe à vous et c'est bien ça disons
que je pourrai pas vous le reprocher
parce que vous restez un vampire c'est
vrai mais lui les différents différent
dans le sens où il m couché avec des
adolescentes elle est transformée en
vampire
je dirais que je suis différent parce
que je n'éprouve aucun plaisir à
commettre des meurtres
sauf quand il s'agit de vos ex c'est un
hasard vous en d'état depuis plus
longtemps qu'elle vous devriez pas être
plus puissant qu elle oui pourquoi vous
l'affrontez bateau seul parce que je
suis impuissant
les vampires combattent électeurs
caquette nom de ce côté là ça va je vous
assure que j'ai des érections phénoménal
j'ai aucun problème à maintenir une
érection
quand je dis un puissant ça signifie que
je ne peux pas me changer en vampire je
n'arrive pas à sortir les crocs pourquoi
c'est parce que vous êtes un gros
connard c'est une longue histoire
mais même si j'arrivais à me transformer
en vampire elle est beaucoup plus forte
que moi j'ai vu de quoi elle était
capable le premier jour et ce n'était
que le début
c'est ça dites plutôt que vous êtes
faible je ne suis par faible elle est
plus forte
je me demandais tout faire de la neige
et le crottin c'est une habitude chez
des vampires oui comme tout ce qu'on
fait on le fait dans la neige et dans le
crottin tu as lu ça dans le guide du
vampire c'est ça j'ai rien dit c'est le
seul endroit du jardin à l'ombre assad
va ok alors c'est moi qui la
maintiendrait au sol parce que ce sera
la partie la plus difficile
toi je veux que tu maintiennent le pieux
en place et tu t'appuies dessus parce
que je suis lourd et ça parce qu'on a
besoin d'être d'accord très près certain
monsieur tient le bien au dessus du
coeur ok et fait attention apam boye et
les doigts toi fred frappe de toutes les
forces essentielles les vampires ont les
eaux particulièrement dures ces papiers
on n'a pas droit à l'erreur
clown ou cette [ __ ] au sol
c'est ma [ __ ] espèces donc tuer
comment on sort d'ici bordel allez vous
faire [ __ ] un décompte respect de
portails de merde connard tu détestes
lieu si tu te casse la figure comme ça
le jour j ça va trop craindre pour nos
gars
[Musique]
ça
c'est dur pour nous tous frais pour vaud
est facile à dire quand
des ancêtres ma dulcinée ça va
[Musique]
vous êtes obligés de participer à la
collecte de sang
elle aura lieu dans la résidence de
sigma tau delta mais crise devrait être
là comment elles vont faire une collecte
de sang chez nous le camion du don du
sang sera garé d'enfants ils auront tout
le matériel dont ils ont besoin notre
rôle à nous est de fournir les en cas et
boissons pour les donneurs tout est
clair
vaches d'avoir un gros frisson vous
étiez où s'est ouvert à comme en avaient
liquidé liquéfié d'une station service
il a fallu faire disparaître les preuves
oui la romance ah oui on s'est éclaté
c'est pour ces pauvres crois qu'on va
vous portez la réunion alors qu'il veut
devenir un vampire
ne soyez pas si timide aller eh ben
voilà
parfait les autres serviront dîner on se
dira ya atroce vous cherche partout
depuis des lustres
je voulais essayer dresse à des crises
de réussie qu'est ce que vous lui avez
fait elle transforme et vit de sa
sororité en vampire
seulement la moitié les autres c'est
leur repas il nous faut un coup de main
qui nous aiderait contre ces maux 1
salut wayne bonjour je n'ai pas pu
m'empêcher de remarquer à quel point ces
fleurs sont excuses ce sont des
chrysanthèmes
j'aime beaucoup marie tu as un conte
très sûr
comment tu connais fred green et ils
nous aident à régler certains détails
techniques de notre stratégie pour tuer
crise elles changent les filles de sa
sororité en vampire elle est forte elle
est même très puissante
pourquoi tu lui infliger ça pour être
franc la vie nous fait de drôles de
surprises parfois et ça n'en est pas une
comme tu le sais déjà
j'ai bien merdé sur ce coup pourquoi
m'as-tu enterré
je ne savais pas
j'ai besoin de ton aide mari fred est
devenu un vampire non non non non il
file un coup de main il va se faire tuer
on a peut-être trouvé un plan d'attaqué
qui peut marcher
je ne voudrais pas tué ma fille c'est au
dessus de mes forces
ouais je m'y attendais tu me donnes ta
bénédiction bon
des mois merde
ce que d'y rester
j'avais faim alors je me suis arrêté en
chemin pour acheter un burrito dans deux
minutes je suis là non vieux ça se
prononcer de façon non tu crées salut
tom j'imagine qu'il doit pleuvoir
aujourd'hui c'est ballot j'ai pas pensé
à emmener mon parapluie
quel boulet alors je constate que vous
avez tout le vôtre ouvert c'est pour
nous protéger des uv très malin de votre
part et donc que suisse en effet
aujourd'hui c'est quoi à ses pontons du
sang dans votre résidence
t'es pas au pour 615 je supposais que
c'était un deal et pour quelles raisons
la météo c'est pour éviter le cancer de
la peau au désolé hockey et empêche fred
vialle est pourquoi j parce que je suis
sûr à 100% qu'il a un souffle au coeur
mais toi tu viens
ah oui je vois le genre je dois filer en
cours avant d'être en retard si tu veux
bien m'excuser
à
merci
franchement si on m'avait dit à quatre
mois que d'ici la fin de ce semestre
je conspiraient pour tuer l'amour de ma
vie car c'est en fait un vampire
psychotique j'aurais répondu c'est du
délire
mais là maintenant que c'est en train de
se faire je regarde ce scénario
improbable d'un autre oeil et je
voudrais j'ai qu'une envie c'est de
l'attrapé par les épaules et de me dire
il coûte ce gars là ç'a l'air dingue
mais il sait parfaitement de quoi il
parle
docteur g non non sale fils de [ __ ]
désolé on dirait que tu avais un
revenant plutôt une bande de vampires
qui essaient de nous tuer ma fraternité
et moi une collecte de sang c'est pas
annulé non elle distribue des tonnes de
flyers et crise a dit tu devais pas
venir à cause de ton souffle au coeur et
j'ai pas de souffle au coeur la garçon
sait aussi que c'est une menteuse
maintenant pourquoi elle veut pas que j
ai écouté ça change rien au projet
d'accord ça nous indique au contraire où
on pourra y trouver
il n'ya plus qu'à nous creuser la
cervelle
[Musique]
ça va aller vous vouliez en clis m'a
invité à votre petite collecte de sang
je lui ai répondu que je ne pourrais pas
venir sauf qu'ensuite j'ai repensé et je
me suis dit arthur tay un égoïste c'est
votre sens là debout et oui j'espère que
ça suffira
parce que je vous avoue que j'ai la tête
qui tous vous pouvez vous assurer que ça
parviennent à christ super ce dès
qu'elle sera qu'en faire c'est sûr viens
tu crois que je vais me coucher de bonne
heure ce soir
puis vous allez dormir ici vous ne me
croiriez pas si je vous disais qu'elle
voit ce machin est confortable
d'user pas prêts à grimper
[Musique]
à bientôt fini bah oui déjà compter sur
nous le salon ferme plutôt le vent et
les siamois débile c'est quoi ce truc
tout nouveaux porte manteau pourquoi
vous avez mis décrocher jusqu'au sol
au cas où des enfants viendraient c'est
plus pratique c'est interdit aux gamins
ici virez moi ce bordel avant la soirée
on vient installer les tables
oui fred tu serais pas là bas il faut
croire qu'il se passe un paquet de trucs
que même dans tes rêves les plus fous tu
aurais pas cru possible
dix cas pas au tout va bien les filles
et toi sa me racaille
je quitte ce nouveau longue survie de la
côte est simple on va vous laisser noir
donc tu ne feras pas là tu préférais que
je reste ici
et bien c'est toi qui vois moi ça m'est
égal annoncé comme ça c'est tout comme
quoi il est vraiment plus que temps
cognac si vous voulez bien nous excuser
[Musique]
chers amis le chat famille l'aude mais
la voilà à quoi je ressemble aujourd'hui
souvenez vous en c'est peut-être la
dernière fois que vous me voyez en vie
sachez que je vous aime et que je fais
tout ça pour vous et pour les cas pas
aux boucles et bien vos ceintures
on va expédier vos miches tout droit en
enfer sale garce
[Musique]
le
ah ah
ah oui
m
oh
[Musique]
hé hé les gars vous allez fini de jouer
à chat bbc oui presque
[ __ ] c'est quoi ce chantier c'est ce
que c'est ok mais le taux de théo nyon
on a besoin de vous en haut à la cuisine
est dégueulasse faudrait la nettoyer si
vous jouez bien vos cartes et que vous
rangez votre chambre peut-être que vous
baisez ce soir je veux dire avec des
filles pour une fois il n'en est pas
question de secondes j'ai un double
appel dû patienter un instant vous en ai
tous saluent alors disons que là tout de
suite fred fichiers sur des détails mais
je pense qu'on devrait pas trop tarder
entendu je te laisse à faut que j'y
aille si jamais tu changes d'avis qu'il
ne trouvera en train de nous entretuer
en 1637 urban pop voilà alors là
donc ça lui est égal que soit là ou pas
mais au départ elle voulait pas me tuer
et maintenant elle va le faire quand
même
et puis je connais non mais elle a
toujours eu l'intention de tuer
seulement elle voulait le garder pour
elle du coup elle a fait genre oh
tant pis ça fait rien tu vois fred sais
pas quoi
[Applaudissements]
elle est due au fait que c'est l'heure
on est parti pour toute la nuit l homme
vous faites surtout pas prendre
à puce
[Musique]
mais elle a dit qu'elle partait on sait
rien zack wright si vous propose qu'on
se casse les mecs c'est bon kamto un
vieux elles nous ont dit pour donner son
sang c'est dehors pour la soirée
attendait à l'intérieur alors on s'en
fout n'a qu'à sortir
regarde moi bien tu trouves que j'ai une
tête à courir dans tous les sens il
égaré vont nous planter ses grillages le
saut gros comme ça
[Musique]
m
canon
c'est ce que tu vois vous ai pas prévu
que c'était une soirée costumée fille
qu'est ce que vous nous racontez pour m
et vous avez tous les goûts bacula sans
dec comment il faut pour tenir
comme les tiennes tête de gland
accompagne mois les tâches faut que je
montre quelques jours j'adorerais mais
carlita déjà réservé pour elle ça te
pose un problème
non loin de là six mois ceux qui veulent
prendre leur pied avec un vent d'hier la
main ok je sais ce qu'on va faire
regarder toi tu prends la fille qui est
là tu montes avec elle et tu lui fais
l'amour j'ai pas dis baiser j'ai dit
faire l'amour
eh bien tu as toi mon grand vient ici et
tu emmènes cette file non toi t'es un
connard
voilà j'ai ouvrirait la fenêtre de
l'intérieur vous pourrez voler jusque là
je suis peut-être balès mais pas à ce
point-là raider et je grimperais au mur
ok on est prêt à passer à l'action
et toi tu es prêt à planter un plus dans
le coeur de celle que tu aime depuis
toujours
tu es obligé de dire de cette foison et
tom essaie de te mettre dans le bon état
d'esprit ok on peut se permettre aucune
hésitation
on a mis des heures à salle et ça et toi
en deux secondes vu tes énervé mieux je
trempe rivasi partenaires de sueur
derrière ce que j'ai à faire
ouais enfin presque à espérer que
personne atterrissent à cet endroit là
c'est quoi ton problème tu m'expliques
sache que j'ai horreur qu'on me fasse
des croche pied c'est interdit aux
filles à l'intérieur désolé tu te fiches
de moi j'ai vu des filles de capa aux
entrées oui parce que c'est une soirée
privée stde est capable ouais c'est
étonnant dommage tant d'années si jeune
[Musique]
et jared tu avais dit qu'il y en aurait
pour tout le monde
ouais c'est ce que j'ai dit parce que
c'est vrai il y en aura pour tout le
monde j'espère j'ai l'impression de
m'être fait chez eux jurent que je vais
m'occuper de toi personne ne sera laissé
de côté
la preuve je me suis même pas servi moi
même alors que ces mois les sons ou quoi
regarder ça nos deux bouffons qui sont
faits vous pour aller à leur soirée
debout les gars pas où elles sont où on
ira tout droit vieux t'inquiète
peut-être que vous y passa aussi si vous
vous asseyez au lieu de continuer vos
conneries boy scout vous êtes vraiment
trop con les mecs vous voyez pas que ce
sont des vampires et qu'elles veulent
tous nous tuer si c'est carrément que
shaw rouillon il est où kyle en eau dans
sa chambre en train de s'envoyer carli
non non pas reste ici tu vas lui casser
son coup qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
c'est une barricade du con ça soit bon
alors vous rester là tant qu'on n'a pas
du tout les vampires c'est clair
car il était là où la porte je peux
occuper mec sort de la violer votre tués
il peut être les prochains temps passé
avec moi ok vous visez bien le coeur et
utiliser un secours pour frapper que
vous ne vouliez pas vous envoyer en
l'air je m'en tape mais vous n'êtes pas
obligé de gâcher le plaisir des autres
d'accord donne les mecs cas elle est
enfermée avec l'une d'elles il faut
qu'on aille le sauver et j'aimerais
savoir simple curiosité est ce que par
hasard tu es gay ça change rien en ce
qui me concerne mais j'aimerais être au
courant je t'explose tatum si j'entends
encore une réflexion on vous dit qu'il
ya des vampires dans cette baraque et
qu'elles veulent nous tuer et si l'une
d'elles décembre que fred et moi soyons
revenus vous l'a plaqué au sol et faites
ce que vous avez à faire c'est plus ou
moins ce que j'avais prévu le gabon
attend je rêve quand mon pantalon
une fois que je serais parti
[Musique]
leclerc
danger
[Musique]
c'est parti saloperie de vampires mais
je parie que tu m'as trois papas j'te
par exient
[Musique]
on n'est jamais trop prudent
mords moi à sa place
pourquoi parce que tu as jugulaire est
plus facile à trouver quoi je vois pas
ce que tu veux que je fasse la ctu ne
dit pas clairement ce que tu veux demain
on y encore ça fait mal
c'est officiel on est des meurtriers à
force on s'y fait quoi les tueurs
ils s'habituent à tuer me regarde pas
avec ces yeux là c'est ma première fois
aussi je te promets comment conserver
vous les poches de sang je vous trouve
bien curieuse jeune fille
je crois qu'un jour ça me plairait
d'organiser ma propre collecte de sang
elles doivent sûrement faire pipi mais
pour la grosse commission suis pas
certain salut fred salut est ce que tu
es au courant qu'on fleurs toutes plus
ou moins avec vous ce soir c'est le
break et corey dommages soient pas
touchés crise a mis une option sur toi
je croyais que ça lui était égal
c'est vrai que tant que ce sont des cas
lignon je suis prêt à m'amuser avec toi
tant qu'on fait ça dans mon lit je peux
regarder
ouais c'est notre truc je suis un voyeur
si vous voulez les tares du baron cool
c'est par ici
j'aime quand ça fait je suis à toi on y
va quand tu peux mon grand tu veux pas
allongé sur le lit d'abord et comme ça
je te rejoindre et je préfère être au
dessus c'est que tu as déjà tout
planifié ce que je vois on a un système
qui marche du tonnerre
je me couche
mais c'est mieux
nat
[Musique]
d'acteurs g que faites-vous sur le toit
oh je veux seulement récupérer mon
frisbee vous jouez à l'ultimate
maintenant au si vous saviez maggie non
plus je crois qu'elle ne va pas s'en
remettre d'ailleurs venez voir
sacrifice attention on n'est jamais trop
prudent
ça a l'air bien et vous voulez que je
vous laisse seul il est chatouilleux
évite de lui faire des bisous dans le
cou
je n'en avais pas l'intention corps ils
sont restés sur elle
[Rires]
[Musique]
puis vint 1er mai weekly médailles entre
on n'a pas croisé
mais fish une de ces trouille plus tard
les grognasses
[Musique]
dieu pourquoi vous me détestez les
débits j'ai vu ce que vous avez fait
dans le jardin ouais mais tu as vu ce
qu'on a fait à samantha non tu as vu ce
qu'on a fait à jared
il est juste là alors tu l'as vu ou pas
toi attrape fred tu tombes c'est du
moyen fessier
à l'est rien louper droite il n'existe
pas j'espère que vous réalisez que c'est
l'échec assuré
qui est là c'est plus ouvert la porte
vous prouvez le
ils ont installé une barricade été
enlevé la tombe énorme appareil photo
toujours à la main voilà c'est
regrettable d'ailleurs parce que sans ça
je ferai certainement demander d'être
nos cavaliers aux bals de l'hiver
t'es sérieux oui mais les choses ont
changé à présent je vais te vider tous
tu veux pas savoir ce que j'aurais
répondu avant est-ce que tu meures ai
répondu vas te faire [ __ ] jeux
restaurants du oui
[Musique]
vous allez vous dépêcher d'ouvrir madame
keller fred green c'est bien toi qu'est
ce que vous faites là la même chose que
vous vous venez nous aider à tuer crise
oui tu l'as trouvé tu te fais une
couleur regardez ce que m'a fait fred
retire le espèce d'abruti je voulais
vous le montrer avant de l'enlever
oh tu sais teinte en brune
c'est pas crise mais sa mère venez vous
battre [ __ ]
[Musique]
attendez elle ment là je le sais j'ai
une meilleure idée ça aurait été bête de
pas s'en servir nos états ne résiste pas
elle est amoureuse de moi c'est fini les
seuls et merde
devinez de qui a tué l'infirmière et
s'est enfui avec les réserves de sang
pourquoi l'aurait-il sens parce que
c'est un super vampire elle va boire
tout le stock pour quoi faire changer
les donneurs en vampire comme elle mais
qu'elle [ __ ]
ça laisse une fille très chouette à part
ça on doit l'arrêter
non si oui
[Applaudissements]
rien ne t'oblige à faire sa marque je
crois que si au contraire
rassure toi quand on y repense sera dans
quelques siècles toute cette histoire
nous fera bien rire tu verras mais pour
l'heure c'est une véritable tragédie jeu
de la corde finissons-en au plus vite au
québec
[Musique]
crise je suis là
crise qu'est ce que tu fais ça se voit
non je coupe le sens aux monsters tu
l'as trouvé ou n'a pas une petite idée
je t'ai vu passer en voiture quand je
suis parti il faut qu'on parle toutes
les deux de quoi tu veux parler
qu'est ce que tu fais avec toutes ses
poches de sang je crée des vampires
c'est pourtant pas sorcier
tu réalises que ces personnes ont une
vie oui qui durera pour toujours
désormais crise tu es vraiment un
vampire diabolique
sans déconner maman j'adore tuent les
gens et j'adore pousser une personne ans
tuée et une autre sans avis donnant que
quelqu'un m'ouvre les veines par pitié
si la conversation la plus forte que
j'ai jamais eu ma vie suis désolé crise
tout ceci est ma faute je sais go
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dr
marie le guay repeat fond ce faire
joli coffret te demande pardon savait
rien
jamais je ferais tuer si tu étais pas à
mon pays je le sais mais moi je t'aurais
tuer mais pas avant d'avoir donné
[Musique]
je défais compilation pour ton ipod
l'enregistrer sur cette clé usb
si m'aurait donné ça et ensuite tu
pourrais tuer non j'aurais tiré à pile
ou face
je l'écouterai chaque fois que gérer
cours et ouais tu es ce qui met à rêver
mieux
je te remercie d merci à toi maman oui
syrie
des tags grosses roues serbe
[Musique]
je rêvais qu'on avait dessus écrit sur
l'a20 saône a tué crise
elle m'a fait une compil
[Musique]
pas maintenant
bien allons voir le frigo j'ai pas fin
aux coupures pour un truc léger à la
haye à eau par exemple - bull fera mal
foire
y'a rien là dedans à part des poches de
sang et des monster je crois que je me
prendrais monster et vous en voulez
on dirait qu'on va avoir d'autres
vampires a tué combien
[Musique]
à
le vieil en faille
[Musique]